smic et minimum vieillesse me lever les
hausse de l'essence probable le week-end
proches accueil glacial pour jean paul
ii ankara première étape de son voyage
en turquie iran nouvelle incertitude
bani sadr remplacé au ministère des
affaires étrangères un monsieur bonsoir
avant toute chose une série de mesures
qui intéresse beaucoup d'entre vous
choque la première reste hypothétique
mais il faut commencer en parler il
s'agit de la prochaine hausse du prix de
l'essence que napanee rené monory le
ministre de l'économie sans toutefois
préciser ni la date peut être dès samedi
ni l'importance en tout cas inférieur à
10 centimes pour le super quoi qu'il en
soit ce sera la cinquième hausse des
prix du carburant depuis le début de
l'année du côté des compensations
maintenant je vais me tourner vers les
fonctionnaires les personnes âgées et
les petits salaires les traitements des
fonctionnaires seront majorés de 1 5% à
compter du 1er décembre
le minimum vieillesse lui passe à 40
francs par jour à compter du 1er
décembre également et le smic est
revalorisé 12 francs 93 de leur ce qui
donne pour un mois normal
2242 francs cela représente une
augmentation d'un peu plus de 4%
le gouvernement a donc donné un coup de
pouce à ses bas salaires qui croise plus
vis désormais que le coût de la vie quel
est aujourd'hui le pouvoir d'achat du
smic est ce qui est inférieur supérieur
à ce qu'il était il ya un an
la réponse n'est pas simple et pour
devenir cette réponse il faut commencer
bien sûr par quelques considérations
techniques la cour des prix et une
course relativement réduit hier tous les
mois et le moment de 0,6 à 1,2 pour cent
selon le rythme de l'inflation
la courbe du smic par contre est une
courbe en forme d'escalier
le smic ne vendent pas régulièrement
tous les mois hilaire et ajuster
automatiquement dès que les prix montent
de 2
pour cent ce qui donne à son évolution
cette forme d'un coup successifs et ce
qui fait par conséquent ce qu'il y a des
moments où le smic et au dessus de la
hausse des prix et des moments où il est
au dessous actuellement et vous le voyez
sur cette courbe le smic
en valeur brute est au dessus de la
hausse des prix mais si l'on tient
compte de l'augmentation des cotisations
sociales en janvier et juillet dernier
et si donc vous ne retient que le
salaire net c'est à dire ce que touchent
réellement le smicard en fin de mois
il apparaît que le smic a pris un retard
de 2 à 3 % sur le coût de la vie bien
alors vous jean marc sauvage vous êtes
je prends tout à fait au smic est ce que
vous constatez quand vous comparez ces
feuilles de salaire d'un an saute
est-ce que vous consultez également une
baisse votre pouvoir d'achat à dire en
gros ça représente 50 francs que c'est
50 francs dans un budget d'un jeune
ménage nous traiterons corruption de ses
vols sur steam
aubut et comment quand vous regardez le
propos est ce que vous pensez que vous
allez rester longtemps comme ça salariés
au smic ont pas beaucoup quand sont
présentés à votre avis quel est le
salaire juste que vous devriez gagner
des messages entrants pour nous pour le
travail qu'on fait sur les 800 mille
salariés au smic que compte la france
la moitié environ comme christine et
jean marc sauvage aux moins de 25 ans
jeunes souvent sans enfants souvent avec
deux salaires ils s'en sortent tant bien
que mal et comme ici ne font leurs
comptes
que de temps en temps il n'en est pas de
même pour ceux qui sont plus âgés et qui
parfois se trouve dans une situation de
famille difficile sur le livre de
comptes apparaissent à leurs dépenses et
recettes au centime près est donc
probable que flo gotha sion 2 4%
d'aujourd'hui permettra en partie de
rattraper ce retard
toutes ces mesures ont été prises en
conseil des ministres et se situe à
diehl porte parole de l'elysée dans la
ligne des décisions du gouvernement pour
aider les plus défavorisés depuis la
rentrée il l'a eu
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire le
complément familial et la prime de
chauffage au cours du même conseil des
ministres raymond barre a estimé que la
situation de l'emploi s'était améliorée
notamment dans le secteur tertiaire
c'est déjà ce que disait le chef de
l'état hier soir à 20h sur antenne 2 un
entretien qui fait pratiquement la une
de tous les journaux aujourd'hui et qui
a suscité vous pouvez vous en douter
nombre de réactions
première d'entre elles celle de michel
rocard dont la prestation à l'émission
de france inter face au public vient
tout juste de terminer nous l'écoutons
ce qui m'a le plus frappé aussi bien en
ce qui concerne les affaires intérieures
de la france qu'en ce qui concerne les
affaires du monde
c'est l'absence dans le propos hier du
président de la république d'une volonté
ferme autour de laquelle puisse
organiser notre avenir proche à quelques
années comment peut-on dire qu'il ne
s'est pas passé d'événements politiques
en france depuis six mois
les grévistes de l'alstom n'admettent
pas qu'on parle de la sorte
ce d'assaut non plus et les aiguilleurs
du ciel pas davantage mais même le vote
du budget mais même les difficultés de
la majorité tout cela sont des
événements politiques que le chef de
l'état prenne ses distances par rapport
à ces événements c'est normal c'est même
bien le moins mais pas de cette manière
pas au point de les nier pas au point de
faire comme s'il ne se passait rien et
qu'on pouvait dormir tranquille tout de
même pas les radicaux de gauche dont
nous entendrons le président michel
crépeau dans notre deuxième journal de
la soirée disent que le président
république a fait bonne analyse mais
qu'il n'a apporté aucune solution qu'une
réponse aux problèmes des français
le communiste andré lajoinie surenchérit
les travailleurs dit ils ont été oubliés
par le chef de l'état ne suffit pas de
parler des grands problèmes du monde
nous sommes prêts à en parler mais il
faut aussi parler de la situation réelle
des français sera en de leurs conditions
de vie et quand les travailleurs voient
que leur niveau de vie
sa baisse avec les fonctions qui ont été
peints sur la sécurité sociale et les
diverses hausses de prix et qui voient
en même temps les profits augmenter de
28% sans que les investissements
créateurs d'emplois d'industrie neusoft
se fasse puisque les chiffres sont là il
n'ya pas création d'emprunts du ciel il
ya régression industriel alors vous
compreniez les travailleurs n'accepte
pas une telle situation irait à chauny
et ils ont raison
pour le journal l'aurore qui a fait
faire un sondage express par l'iffhs rsa
sondage qui paraîtra demain 44 % des
téléspectateurs hier soir regardez cet
entretien les autres réactions
maintenant compagnie de jean-louis scène
et de pearl pour jean lecanuet de l'udf
le président giscard d'estaing parlait
le langage de la mesure et de la vérité
il a donné des réponses concrètes aux
véritables préoccupations des français
au parti radical socialiste didier
bariani estime qu une nouvelle fois le
président de la république a su dresser
un tableau lucide des problèmes de
l'heure pas de réaction officielle ou
fpr mais olivier guichard ne partage pas
la sérénité du chef de l'état pour lui
s'il n'y a pas de crise de régime
il y as crise de la majorité huguette
bouchardeau du ps us de manques je cite
si les dissertations appliqué du chef de
l'état suffiront longtemps à jouer le
rôle de tranquillisants chez les
syndicats pas de réaction officielle de
la cgt pour la cfdt il ya compte
diction les français qui sont de plus en
plus inquiets ont vu leur président à
prendre de plus en plus d'autres la cftc
estime je cite que plus ça change plus
c'est pareil
andré bergeron de force ouvrière partage
l'analyse du chef de l'état sur la
situation internationale mais pas sur la
situation sociale de la france pour la
cgc enfin l'optimisme montré par valéry
giscard d'estaing en matière économique
et sociale aurait besoin d'être
davantage justifier l'origine de prendre
un petit peu de recul 24 heures après ou
de hauteur c'est le mot à la mode et
commentez vous le voyez par notre ami
gus et revenons avec vous une heure les
copains sur ce qui vous a frappé dans
ses propos présidentiels d'abord une
démarche
eh bien oui je crois que pour qualifier
cette démarche il faudrait prendre trois
mots utilisés par monsieur giscard
d'estaing lui-même lorsqu'il parlait de
la situation économique mais je crois
qu'à travers ces trois mots donc on
retrouve les caractères de cette
démarche qu'il veut donner chaque fois
qu'il de mois en mois une veille
s'adresse aux français il y à la gravité
pour juger la situation la volonté pour
en sortir et la confiance pour voir
l'avenir la gravité je crois qu'elle
s'accompagne à vrai dire toujours d'une
certaine sérénité
même quand le président de la république
dépeint ce qu'il appelle la
désorganisation du monde c'est toujours
en fait le ton de l'analyse qu'il
emploie une analyse d'ailleurs qui
replace les problèmes français dans un
cadre planétaire la volonté le président
présente sa politique comme une
politique qui sait où elle va et qui
parfois prend de grands risques et donne
deux exemples sa politique africaine et
la politique économique de monsieur bah
enfin la confiance dans l'avenir est là
le président répond au pessimisme qui
l'a remarqué dans ses conversations avec
deux jeunes français à l'occasion de ses
derniers voyages en province et cette
confiance elle-même elle est raisonnable
elle est mesurée
elle s'appuie sur des points forts mais
il reconnaît l'existence de points
faible gravité volonté confiance je
crois qu'à travers ces termes le
président de la république s'efforce
toujours d'expliquer alors puis et la
fameuse affaire des diamants et un salon
de commandes d'atr sont restés sur leur
faim non pas tant sur son attitude en
tant que président la république depuis
son accession à l'elysée mais plutôt sur
la fameuse affaire la plaquette de 60
trilogie je disais qu'elle le prétend
appliquer c'est toujours d'expliquer et
là il a volontairement renoncé à
l'explication il explique bien sûr son
attitude en tant que président de la
république en particulier les raisons
pour lesquelles elle a renoncé à toute
poursuite est également l'usagé qui est
fait des cadeaux qu'ils
soit autant que par exemple la
république une pétition statut il n'est
pas contre un statut qui soit même
légiférer afin qu'il soit traduit par
une loi prochainement
mais concernant donc cette affaire est
dite des diamants de bokassa
il tranche il dément et se démentit
concerne la valeur des cadeaux qu'il
aurait reçues il dit lui même que c'est
un démenti catégorique et surtout en
insistant
un démenti qui est méprisant tout porte
à croire qu'il en restera là lors la
question qu'on peut se poser un démenti
de cette nature est il suffisant pour
convaincre et nous touchons là je crois
un problème essentiel du problème de la
vie politique française la vie politique
française qui est le problème de la
confiance quand un homme d'état explique
longuement sa politique ou quand un
homme d'état tranche et dément de façon
brève
les démarches sont très différentes mais
finalement le succès des démarches
repose toujours sur la confiance et le
crois que c'est encore plus vrai dans un
système de démocratie présidentielle
comme le nôtre chaque fois que le
président de la république qui s'adresse
au pays
il s'agit toujours de conflit mais télé
puisque nous évoquions la sphère des
diamants cette réaction publiée dans le
matin aujourd'hui par le directeur du
canard enchaîné roger fressoz nous
répliquerons mercredi prochain de façon
extrêmement précise aux assertions vague
du chef de l'état dit donc le patron du
canard enchaîné un député socialiste a
même posé la question cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale pour qu'elle va
leur demande de raymond forni pour
quelle valeur monsieur giscard d'estaing
at il déclaré en douane et diamants qui
lui ont été offertes en 73 c'était
pendant la séance dite des questions au
gouvernement
aussitôt après la discussion du projet
de loi sur l'ivg et g s'est poursuivie
dans un climat disons assez des
passionnés en tout cas sans grand éclat
on en saura un petit peu plus demain
après midi car certains députés de la
majorité ont demandé que la loi sur
l'avortement donc ne soit reconduite
qu'à titre provisoire pour 1 2 ou 5 ans
mais de cela les élus d'opposition ne
veulent pas réponse donc demain le pape
en turquie maintenant les premiers
télégrammes et six notes premier contact
avec nos envoyés spéciaux faisait état
d'un accueil à ces glaces et ankara au
propre comme au figuré
mais tout doucement à force de sourire
de gestes c'est touchant de jean paul ii
l'atmosphère nous dit-on 7 un petit peu
rythme étrange première journée
accueil réservé même froid et des
questions qui se posent déjà sur les
conséquences de ce voyage ce matin à
l'aéroport il n'y avait ni foule ni
chaleur
il est vrai que les consignes de
sécurité empêcher à tout curieux de
s'approcher de l'aéroport le spectacle a
été le même cet après-midi au mausolée
d'atatürk le fondateur de la république
on ya vu l'armée le pape sa suite et
quelques officiels quant aux
conséquences de ce voyage elles
dépendent d'abord de ce que va dire jean
paul ii déjà cet après midi il a écrit
sur le livre d'or du mausolée que le
gouvernement des peuples est aux mains
du seigneur
une phrase qui a provoqué de réaction
étonnement chez ceux qui rappelle que
l'état turc est d'abord laïque et puis
satisfaction chez d'autres nostalgiques
du rôle et de l'importance de la
religion
demain avec la rencontre à istanbul du
patriarche dimitrios premier jean pts 2
horace osaka doute une journée plus
facile et un accueil chaleureux car le
dialogue est déjà bien avancées entre
les deux églises romaines et orthodoxes
la question qui reste posée ce soir est
de savoir si le pape
profitant de son séjour en turquie
s'adressera également au monde musulman
et indirectement aux iraniens oui
patricia charnelet nous disait que les
catholiques étaient extrêmement
minoritaire dans ce pays à grande
majorité musulmane
paul 6 avait déjà tenté un rapprochement
entre les deux communautés
ce voyage de jean-paul ii s'inscrit dans
le sillage tracé par police qui avait
rencontré athénagoras ce à trois
reprises en terre sainte à
constantinople et enfin à rome
dès 1964 les liens étaient donc renouer
entre les deux églises catholique et
orthodoxe qui était séparé depuis le 11e
siècle mais vous avec les sentiments de
celui que nous avons conscience de
représenter que le prophète on annonçait
jadis sous le nom de la paix c'est
également sous le signe de la paix que
jean paul 2 places ce voyage en
s'entretenant à istanbul avec le
successeur d'athéna gauras le patriarche
a bon côté il semble qu'il y ait pas un
problème je crois que vous êtes rendu
compte par vous même et nous allons voir
tout à l'heure si nous pouvons refuser
ce sujet de patricia charnel pas
d'inquiétude aujourd'hui puisque nous
parlons du voyage de jean-paul ii en
turquie pas d'inquiétude pour les suites
des menaces du fou qui voulaient
assassiner le pape
en revanche des sueurs froides
aujourd'hui pour les services de
sécurité du sénateur edward kennedy
ils ont intercepté de justesse une jeune
femme qui brandissait un poignard de
chasse et qui tentaient de pénétrer dans
le bureau du sénateur au capital mais
sans doute voir maintenant les toutes
premières images de la mecque en arabie
saoudite vous allez apercevoir cela va
aller très vite
l'une des colonnes de la grande mosquée
le nombre d'impacts des balles prouve
donc que les combats ont dû être très
violent les autorités saoudiennes
confirme qu'un groupe d'insurgés
continuent de résister dans les sous
sols sur la manière utilisée pour
capturer les premiers rebelles et bien
des gaz brûlants l'oxygène et des gaz
lacrymogènes
et c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
avez vu ces hommes masque iran une
dernière dépêche kim étendue à l'instant
et qui nous vaut un coup de téléphone de
philippe rochot qui nous l'a appris il
s'agit de la disgrâce de monsieur bani
sadr qui reste ministre délégué des
finances mais qui ne sera plus
responsable des affaires étrangères il
vient à l'instant d'être remplacé car
les choses vont vraiment très vite en
iran d'être remplacé par monsieur gaudin
avait tout de suite donc
philippe rochot des lettones donc si
tout va bien normalement ce devrait être
monsieur gods années et non pas monsieur
bani sadr qui se rendrait à new york
pour le conseil de sécurité des nations
unies qui vous savez doit discuter de la
question iranienne
cela dit je le répète encore à téhéran
les choses vont extrêmement vite et il
nous faut donc attendre des
confirmations les otages de l'ambassade
serait selon jimmy carter détenus dans
les conditions que le président
américain a qualifié de honte pour la
civilisation il serait en effet pieds et
poings liés au bout de trois semaines et
n'aurait pas l'autorisation de parler
l'envoyé spécial iranien à l'onu a quand
même essayé de rassurer courte valdan
toutes les mesures garantissant la
protection des otages ont été prises dit
il et puis j'ajoute que le gouvernement
iranien a déposé aujourd'hui une plainte
contre le shah d'iran devant un tribunal
de l'état de new york afin de récupérer
les 20 milliards de dollars qui auraient
été détournés par l'ancien souverain
l'ancien souverain qui devrait bientôt
quitter le territoire américain
le parti toudeh autrement dit le parti
communiste iranien s'est rallié à la
révolution islamique de l'ayatollah
khomeini mais on se demande s il le
soutenait vraiment bien philippe rochot
a demandé à son secrétaire général s'il
approuvait la prise d'otages à
l'ambassade américaine
réponse affirmative je crois que dans
tout le monde on est beaucoup de pays
aux mesures
révolution iranienne avait quitté maître
de la bourgeoisie de la démocratie
bourgeoise de l'europe occidentale mais
on ne peut pas mesurer toujours des
actions d'une révolution de telle
envergure qu'il a été un iran et qui est
maintenant qui est entré dans sa
deuxième phase beaucoup plus approfondie
que la première phase 2 février de
mesurer à visiter ses maîtres il faut
trouver des maîtres pour cela il faut
aussi penser que les usa ont fait une
grande honte honte une grande activité
anti populaire anti national compte les
voix de notre nation et que leurs
activités politiques
déjà du temps de mon salaire de dr house
à dire et était toujours pour écraser
notre indépendance notre liberté en iran
on ne peut pas mesurer les relations de
l'iran avec l'impérialisme américain
dans le cadre des relations
diplomatiques normales d international
s'est pas assez les membres et nos
relations avec un c'est toujours une
relation de diers de relations de
ghettos deguire et dans ce cadre je
crois que cette action de l'ambassade
américain que nous nous appellons de
centres d'espionnage américain on ne la
paie pas l'ambassade marquant en iran
c'est un action juste cette action qui
est dans lost dans le cadre de nous deux
ne droit national voilà ce soir pour
lire en union soviétique la nomination
hier de nicolaï tikhonov 74 ans comme
membre du politburo semble bien prouver
théâtre santé d'alexis kossyguine est
plus grave qu'on ne le pensait sur ces
images de la session d'automne du soviet
suprême
on ne voit pas alexis kossyguine il est
absent de toute vie publique depuis
maintenant un mois et demi cette
élection ne remplace pas de ce côté
guide mais il est troublant de constater
que c'est son premier adjoint
il vient d'être élu le sommet de dublin
maintenant dans son intervention une
guerre antenne 2 le chef de l'état
disait quand on entre dans une
institution on commence par en respecter
les règles c'était une allusion bien sûr
à la grande bretagne qui aimeraient bien
révisé à son profit les règles de la
communauté européenne le sommet qui
s'ouvre demain à dublin sera donc
difficile mais jusqu'où pouvait aller
madame thatcher
c'est la question que s'est posée à
londres philippe harrouard il se l'est
posée et j'espère qu'il va nous la poser
je confirme qu'à dublin je ne me
contenterai pas d'une demi miche de pain
margaret thatcher à l'issue du sommet
franco britannique
pour elle ce que la grande-bretagne
verse au budget la communauté doit être
équivalent à ce qu'elle reçoit or l'an
prochain on en sera loin puisque le
déficit s'élèvera à 10 milliards de
francs
impossible injuste réplique madame ce
match on a beau faire remarquer aux
anglais que c'est de leur faute qu'il
existe des règles qui sont les mêmes
pour tous
eh bien il n'y a qu'à modifier les
règles répond-t-il crûment la politique
agricole commune représente 70% du
budget communautaire
or ce secteur n'intéresse guère les
anglais qui importent beaucoup de
produits du commonwealth il réclame donc
une réduction des dépenses agricoles de
la cee
autre argument à l'heure où la grande
bretagne pratiquer une politique
draconienne d'austérité comment
peut-elle se permettre de verser 10
milliards à la communauté mais fait-on
remarquer si la grande bretagne ne paie
pas il faudra que d'autres pays le
fassent pourquoi les pénaliser eux à
londres
on ne veut pas le savoir tout cela est
largement exposé dans la presse comme si
on assistait à une campagne
d'orchestration la france apparaît comme
l'opposant numéro un aux revendications
britannique et un journal parlait même
de boycotter les produits français
réponse de paris nous sommes simplement
pour l'application des règles pas du
tout contre une discussion et surtout
pour une cohésion de la communauté lundi
rôle schenker président de la commission
de bruxelles est venu présenter des
propositions pouvant servir de base aux
entretiens de dublin
cela reviendrait à réduire de 40 % la
contribution britannique s'est
semble-t-il jugé insuffisant ici car si
madame thatcher se sent forte c'est
qu'elle est suivie par l'ensemble des
anglais comme l'a montré un récent débat
au parlement
conservateurs et travaillistes anti et
pro européen se retrouve dans une sorte
d'union sacrée derrière le premier
ministre des affaires sociales
maintenant avec tout d'abord cette
dernière dépêche décidément la fuite est
très chargé aujourd'hui parution normal
de nice matin
donc demain matin mais est ce la ne veut
pas dire que le débat que le conflit
soit clos maintenant le début de la
campagne des prud'hommes qui a commencé
sur antenne 2 d'antenne 2010 à 12h45 qui
se déroulera pendant deux semaines vous
savez que les élections prud'homales ont
lieu le 12 décembre
voici tout d'abord un extrait de ce que
disait le représentant de la cgc
d'antenne de mythes monsieur 200 à
conseiller prud'homal cgc doit avoir
présent à l'esprit que l'encadrement est
à la charnière entre la direction et le
personnel d'exécution
ce qui fait que les rapports sont
parfois difficiles et un conseiller
prud'homme cgc parce qu'il est il vit
ces problèmes et mieux' acte que
quiconque à pouvoir les apprécier et à
les régler au mieux des intérêts de
chacun on ne sait pas assez que le rôle
des prud'hommes est avant tout de
concilier et bien souvent nous avons
vécu cela que de un cadre et un
employeur n'était pas d'accord ou un
employeur et son agent de maîtrise
n'était pas d'accord ils viennent devant
les conseils des prud'hommes
on s'explique on discute il y à une
concertation et finalement ça permet aux
rapports dos aux deux personnes de
continuer leur collaboration catastrophe
aérienne un dc10 néo zélandais ayant à
son bord 2 157 passagers s'est écrasé
dans l'antarctique on ne connaît
toujours pas le nombre des victimes et
on craint qu'il n'y ait aucun survivant
à bord de l'avion qui effectué une
excursion au dessus des glaces polaires
se trouverait dit on seraient n'goni la
risle premier homme à avoir conquis
l'everest et dc 10 sont décidément
frappé par le sort un appareil de ce
type
appartenant à une compagnie américaine a
dû se poser quelques minutes après son
décollage de londres l'un de ses moteurs
étaient tombés en panne
jan fabre condamné à six mois de prison
dont cinq avec sursis le président du
parti radical italien a jugé pour
insoumission était en prison depuis un
mois il a donc purgé sa peine mais après
sa libération il s'est présenté à sa
caserne et c'est là qu'il a appris qu'il
était exempté du service national sports
tous les amateurs de football savent
qu'en ce moment même saint-etienne est
en train de rencontrer l'équipe d'aris
salonique en huitièmes de finale de la
coupe de l'uefa mais ils ne savent
peut-être pas que l'on a commencé il ya
seulement dix minutes car olivier rey il
ya eu beaucoup de brouillard
oui patrick comme nous pouvons le
constater sur ces images il n'y a
vraiment pas beaucoup de visibilité au
stade geoffroy guichard
et c'est donc avec 20 minutes de retard
que l' arbitre allemand monsieur ed
weiler a sifflé le coup d'envoi de ce
huitième de finale de coupe de l'uefa
qui oppose donc l' as st-etienne anvers
contre l'aris de salonique résultat de
cette rencontre à 23h dans le journal
d'hervé claude si le brouillard le veut
bien d'accord résultat qui nous sera
donnée par bernard père qui se trouve
sur place et qui s'y trouve en compagnie
de gérard holtz et d'olivier à brax
olivia bras n'est pas une de nouvelles
nouvelles recrues il n'a qu'une dizaine
d'années c'est l'un des jeunes reporters
d'antenne 2 que nous avons choisie pour
effectuer une série de petits reportages
en fonction d'une grande émission que
nous consacrerons aux enfants le lundi 7
janvier toute la soirée sera consacrée
aux enfants et c'est eux qui ont composé
un petit peu cette émission en parlant
des problèmes qui agitent le monde de
l'enfance malheureuse la guerre mais
aussi de ceux qui passionnent les jeunes
c'est à dire la pop music
la moto et le sport vous allez écouter
maintenant la réaction de ce jeune
garçon qui se trouve en sont même au
stade geoffroy guichard
olivia brasse exprimé dans le journal de
noël mamère
c'est l'avis écouter le bonheur qui
l'exprimé d'être à geoffroy guichard
si tu le brouillard veut gêner le
déroulement de la partie et je ne sais
pas si la partie va avoir lieu pourquoi
dis moi olivier girard pourriez vous
demander olivier quelle impression cela
lui fait se trouvait transformés en
reporters plus en plein dans l'actualité
que je vous dis bien sûr mais quel
problème gurria nous vous remercions de
cette information mais leur ligue et l'a
aidé à me demande quelle quelle
impression ce avons fait douter leur
poubelle ils racontent leur parterre
d'enfants meurent
eh bien écoutez olivier je vais te faire
une confidence
le rêve d'aujourd'hui eh bien il va y
avoir je crois une dizaine de rêve
puisque nous allons avoir vous le savez
une dizaine de grands reporters qui vont
partir aux quatre coins du monde
ouais ce qui se disait donc il y à une
heure et demie et c'est vrai que cette
émission du 7 janvier au soir est
consacré à tous ces enfants qui ont en
gros entre 11 et 15 ans est peut-être
l'un d'entre eux un jour se retrouvera
dans notre équipe g20 tout cas tout le
bien que je lui souhaite
les brouillards sur le stade de geoffroy
guichard ne sont pas seuls une grande
partie du pays en est recouverte une
seule exception quand même le littoral
méditerranéen
demain et bien le temps sera
généralement brumeux encore et frais le
matin et ensoleillé dans l'après-midi
avant de vous quitter une série de
chiffres avec tout d'abord les
pronostics de pierrette brès pour le
prix de valence et qui se disputait à
vincennes elle a choisi en pronostics le
5 le 8 le 19 le 6 le 1 ou las comme vous
le voulez le 17 le 15 et le xiii ce sont
donc les choix de qian bresse pour le
tiercé de demain
d'autres chiffres avec les résultats du
loto pour gagner il fallait jouer le 2
le 4 le 22 le 28 le cac 40 est le 43
comme numéro complémentaire est le 33
voilà ce journal se termine maintenant
votre dernier rendez vous avec
l'information ce sera 22h55 hervé claude
et puis demain à 12h45
comme tous les jours patrick lecocq à
demain en ce qui me concerne 20 heures
bonne soirée à tous
à